my good buddy from way back in the day
at the worldwide leader in sports and
who is the host of college gameday and I
watch him every single Saturday my
six-year-old coupe is so locked in he
he's locked in watching every single
minute and I love the fact that he's
getting grown up having rece Davis be
the guy who he watches every single
Saturday on ESPN it kind of makes you
gives me the warm and fuzzies Rhys Yuri
back here on the show how are you Rhys
I'm doing great rich and that that's
very kind it's true oh you're so let's
have your son out to the show sometime
that'd be great
well here's the neat thing to Rhys cuz
you know you and I did I think you and I
did a ton of 2 a.m. sports centres when
I first got there before I even started
doing things regularly with Stewart and
then you were doing your own thing as
well you know he because you guys have
incorporated Chris FeliCa onto the show
the bear okay you know he gives you his
picks and and I just knew him as the
researcher when I first started there so
haven't coop my son coop tell me about
bears bank and what Chris FeliCa is
coming up with it's Suzy to kunos for
leaks from back in the day it blows my
mind
Rhys it's pretty cool it's amazing
predating my arrival to the show they
didn't have a guest picker one week and
somebody said hey why don't we put
FeliCa on there and he was so good and
you know all the information and he can
generate it's taken taking on a life but
so we had a show earlier this year where
there was a kid who dressed up like the
bear and brought his own little bear
Bank and we brought him up on the set
I'd love to see him maybe here in the
Schwab we can have him we can get to
Howie back on there and different
generations of stumping going on and I
know Chris is a big you guy and so here
we are that's a huge game for this
Saturday I guess let's start there since
it's Clemson's number one in the college
football playoff rankings how do you see
the ACC championship working on Saturday
I think it i think it's a de facto
quarterfinal rich i think it's very
simple the winner makes it in under the
right set of circumstances should
clemson lose a close game I could see
them still remaining in the four
would have to be a particular set of
circumstances but the simplest way is to
say winter is going to be in the playoff
and that's as it should be
I think Clemson is the better team I
think their defensive line is the best
position group in all of college
football and I use that as a group
because Baker Mayfield obviously at
least in my judgment the best player in
college football and I expect Clemson to
win but you know Miami has been Miami
has been resurgent and they certainly
want to prove something after what
happened last week ya know and I saw
Michael Irvin last night obviously part
of the Thursday Night Football in Dallas
and he's just you know he's so fired up
because it looks like his sons gonna get
some playing time based on some of the
injuries that have happened to the
receiving corps yeah they was they lost
two of their better targets I'm on
Richards wide receiver and then Chris
Herndon in and that's where Michael Suns
going to step into that role which is a
spot that Miami has used that particular
receiver hybrid spot in a lot of a lot
of different ways lining them up
different plays has been an important
third down target for them so Michael
son will have a chance to have an impact
on the game Saturday night for sure and
the SEC championship game that goes on
for hours before the ACC championship
game I would would you say that's a de
facto quarterfinal as well absolutely
yeah that one that would that one for
sure because Auburn is already number
two if Georgia avenges it's only lost by
beating over and they'll be in the
playoffs - I didn't see anything in that
first meeting that would indicate to me
that in three weeks time Georgia could
change enough to beat Auburn they seemed
to me to get manhandled on both lines of
scrimmage particularly Georgia's
offensive line got handled they already
are reluctant to pass I wouldn't say
they struggle to do it because they've
been fairly effective this season
throwing the ball they just don't do it
much because of the freshman quarterback
they're gonna have to Saturday if
they're going to move the ball and will
they be able to protect Jake from long
enough because Auburn's guys really
stout defensive front good pass rushers
I think that's going to be quite a
challenge for Georgia on Saturday
Reese Davis College GameDay is host here
on the Rich Eisen show all right
me the scenario that puts Alabama in
what's the most likely scenario that
that that that puts the Crimson Tide and
despite not even being part of a
conference championship Saturday game I
would say it's probably Ohio State
beating Wisconsin and not doing so 59 to
nothing as they did a few years ago I
think that would be the most likely
scenario the other one that I could see
would be TCU knocking off Oklahoma now
both of those things happen I think it's
uh there's a really good chance that
Alabama would be in the playoffs if one
of those happen that's the best scenario
most likely one that would get them in
but I think there will be a lot of there
would be a lot of drama and a lot of
Anchorage I said this to Kirby hoe cut
on our Frankie show the other night
committee can't win with that choice
between Ohio State and Alabama if it
comes down to that I mean and that's not
the way the voting goes but if those are
the two most likely candidates because
should for the third time in four years
you know the three-card Monte the shell
game however you want to say it you know
they flip and reveal and hey Ohio State
wins again you know as the things go
around they're going to be criticized
for that if they choose Alabama then
it's going to be well you guys always
give Alabama more credit than they've
earned this particular team didn't earn
it and all of that kind of thing so if
it comes down to those two teams I
really don't envy the committee because
they're that answer will not be
satisfactory
whichever answer it is to a majority of
non Ohio State or not an Alabama fan but
if Ohio State does win that game how
does the selection committee not put the
Big Ten Champion in the Final Four for
the second straight year I think if they
don't it will be the albatross of easily
to me the worst loss in the playoffs era
by anyone considered a contender and
that's the loss at Iowa now following
being the Michigan man you are you know
how it is in Iowa it's nice it's nice go
yeah but you go up there and typically
how you lose is you lose by some score
that nobody's ever seen in a football
game know somebody like you're like 1918
you know 15 12 and somebody makes or
misses a field goal at the end of the
game and all the people run out and
they're excited
and you know he said well it happened
again this wasn't that I mean they gave
up fifty five points to a team that
hadn't even scored twenty in two months
against any team not named Illinois you
know I mean fifty five they're gonna be
about thirty one point and you know I've
heard people say well you know it's you
know this team's trending that way that
game didn't happen in July you know I
mean that was a November game and I
think if they don't make it that that
will be at that combined with the
decisive loss that they had home to
Oklahoma well and and and so let's get
to what I've been talking about all week
and I'll do it every single year until
it happens an eighth team playoff
because we're not even talking about the
pac-12 championship game is that's that
that's a good point I know that is a
moot point TCU has truly no chance to
get in even if they beat Oklahoma I I I
understand that there's a dumb and
Dumberer chance I get it wouldn't we
want to see an undefeated UCF team maybe
be some sort of Cinderella in the same
way that we see a 12 seed or a 13 seed
and March Madness I mean aren't we
aren't we taking all of this potential
fun away at the expense of of the
conversations that we're having right
now well I mean that's a that's a
reasonable point but I'm not sure that
the benefit outweighs the cost to it
because if if you did expand it then
last week in Auburn didn't mean let me
stop you there how about then then then
if you're in seeded five through eight
you have to play a road game at the home
of one through four I would I mean look
that would there's going to come a day
rich where I think that's going to
happen I still prefer the exclusivity of
making it difficult to get into the
playoffs - I don't want they protect the
regular-season because you know this
whole every game counts mantra is going
to go by the board either way you slice
it because if I mean assuming that
somebody either Oklahoma or Wisconsin
gets beat it's going to go by the board
because if Alabama gets in use they will
wind in the Auburn game count or if I Oh
state
right in the Iowa game cow but I still
think that the exclusivity serves the
sport well right now things evolve over
time and there will come a time when we
go to a tiff when we do I hope that they
do exactly what you're talking about and
play those first-round games on campus
because you're already seeing the
difficulty for some fan bases
particularly ones that have been in the
playoff multiple years it's it's hard to
set aside I mean the finances are
certainly difficult it's hard for most
people who even do have the means to set
aside the time to be able to go back to
back and be hanging in limbo as to
whether you'll travel to the side of the
championship game the second week or you
skip the semis and wait and go to that
one all of those types of things are are
important for the atmosphere in the
stadium so I hope if they ever do expand
it which I'm sure they will at some
point I hope they do exactly what you're
saying and play the first round camp all
right rece Davis crystal ball it for me
although that's my favorite coaching
cliche I don't have a crystal ball do
you think what do you think I think it
will be I think Clemson will win I think
Auburn will win so they'll be the first
two and I think Oklahoma will win to be
the third but I still even though it's
getting awfully trendy and talking too
much I think Wisconsin will lose and I
suspect that ultimately they will choose
Alabama to be the support table Penn
State fans would rejoice if that
happened if Ohio State had has done to
it what happened to Penn State for Ohio
State's sake last year I think I think
Penn State might have a national holiday
if something yeah the caveat I offer is
if Ohio State hammers Wisconsin and you
could ask me that that question and I'll
and I'll change it to a holiday we know
if it's 20 to 17 don't you know then
probably not well do we know and it's
part I've been in the Dallas Metroplex
area and then also steroid haze because
I have a back issue
what's JT Barrett's status do we know
he's expected to play he had a little
surgical procedure on his knee they
called it minor but you know what minor
surgery is something to happen to
someone else that's great you know but
he's supposed to play they expect him to
be able to go okay and you're going to
Clemson right that's for you guys are we
yeah we are here we're in Charlotte
right now for Clemson I am oh that's
right the iord Charlotte okay who's your
guest picker can you tell me yes I can
well I sure hope I'm going to anyway yes
all right and they'll yell at me later
it's going to be uncle Luke Luther
Campbell okay oh nice all right I
suggested that every time he makes it
pick the core so likes of course so just
slaps a hundo on him right there like
uncle Lucas through the canes back in
the day well I mean you should get her
Vaughn to your arms gonna be there he's
gonna be oh yeah he's not missing his
for a chance to play for a playoff oh
yeah trust me all of us at game day
morning we are we're on pins and needles
that he's gonna make it for our one at
6:00 a.m. Pacific on Sunday but he's
gonna be there I'll be there tell them
to get off some of that cash and get on
one of those wheels up Michael taking
right after the game no problem I got it
Reese thanks for calling and we'll be
tuned in coupe and I other kids will
drag him in the room to you guys Reese
Davis at ESPN underscore rece Davis for
more Rich Eisen show tuned - audience
Channel 239 or DirecTV or download the
doesn't show up